hello today i want to show you how to
draw a perfect egg using geometry okay
so what i'm mixing is formal geometry
with nature and this nature wonderful so
what i've got is five dots here which
i've already mapped out to make a
pentagon if i threw it away it would be
a penta
gone but it's here and inside the
pentagon i'm gonna form a pentagram the
pentagram was used by the pythagorean
cult in southern italy the followers of
pythagoras and they felt it was magic
just magic
and in a way i agree with them
so a pentagon in a pentagram
you need to join
opposite
corners wonderful thing about the
pentagon is all these lines are divided
by golden ratio there's two things you
can measure you can measure that
distance there short distance to the
side or the long distance across there
divide that into there you always get
the golden ratio but even when you split
it up again divide that into that golden
ratio and it's it's just absolutely
beautiful but how am i going to form
an egg
something that's natural something has a
natural shape in nature
well a few more lines okay first of all
through this point here parallel to the
base i'm going to draw another line
now two more lines one from there the
end of that one to there
and one from here to there
and all my line drawing
is complete
now for the egg a hen is a production
line of eggs
there are nine
in the process from the very smallest to
the one that's going to be delivered
today and it's the one that's delivered
today that i'm going to show you now
first of all
i'm going to ask you which end of an egg
comes out first
the thin end or the thick end did you
know i'll tell you the answer is
the thicker end
why and i'm going to explain that what
i'm going to do now is draw a semicircle
it's going to go from this point here
down here
now it nearly
coincides with the bottom line but it
doesn't it overlaps it slightly what i'm
drawing
shows you just how the hens egg is laid
because when it's laid the shell is soft
and as it's soft the egg inside has been
more or less a perfect ball
and as it begins to be laid it's pushed
out just like a water bubble
coming out
from the bath
a perfect
hemisphere a perfect heart sphere and
that's what i've drawn here and that's
the bottom of the egg
as it
does it grow johnny because it doesn't
come out presumably the hole in the
chicken's not that big so it comes out
thin and then the whole the whole
stretch is
perfectly to cope right and it allows it
and of course the pressure inside the
body is pushing it out but it acts just
like water forming a perfect hemisphere
right when it's half out already it's
beginning to solidify
but the rest has to be
thrown out and the rest is forced out
through the pressure inside
but now i need some more curves so i'm
going to take the end line end point
there
and stretch that out to here
and draw that that's it i've got it
going now and from the other end i draw
that right on the point and there it
goes and we've nearly got our egg
now we've got one more curve to make and
that's the top of the egg and for that
you need a center here on the leg
there
and now i turn that around
it should complete the top of the egg
like that
and there we have our perfect egg and if
you don't believe me
if i bring this to the towards the
camera
i'll give you that
my dad used to say i've got an egg here
fresh
i caught it dropping
so that means it would the shell
wouldn't have been solid because it only
solidifies once it's out and the air
gets to it and its reaction with the air
but it's very beautiful i don't know any
more mathematics that goes with this at
all other than the thing is beautiful
and it links nature
to geometry
and i love them both
cheers
if you'd like to go even deeper into the
mathematics behind egg shapes this
reasonably recent paper may maybe of
interest they were chasing a universal
formula for egg shape
now for chicken eggs it looks like this
but for more pear-shaped so-called
pyraform eggs you need this one
meaning the universal egg formula well
it's this whopper
the four parameters are the egg's length
breadth shift of a vertical axis and the
diameter at one quarter egg length
if you'd like to check it out read all
the details we'll include a link to the
paper in the video description
and over on our extras number file 2
channel you can see an interview i've
just done with a ukrainian poultry
engineer who helped create the formula
that's worth a look to
the principles of evolution
yeah
to deduce another more complicated
formula so it it appeared to be very
complicated it appeared to be awful from
from my point